hello i'm luis from belgium my name is
maria but you can call me goodie hi
everyone hi i'm originally from india
and also grew up in china and dallas
texas but actually spent most of my life
growing up here in beautiful guatemala
my name is yasu i'm originally from kobe
japan the home of your favorite kobe
beef hi my name is sambar i'm from
mumbai india hi everyone i'm samina from
new york hey everyone my name is fur and
i'm from manila philippines hey guys
this is peter from paris hi i'm arthur
from st petersburg russia i'm speaking
to you from beautiful badlands national
park south dakota
and i just want to say i can't wait to
meet everybody and get started at the
gsb hi my name is maria and i have from
uppsala sweden i used to be a concert
pianist a quick fun fact about me is
that i've met the queen of england
somehow twice
i'm literally moving to the other side
of the world so this feels incredibly
exciting and yet absolutely terrifying
one fun fact about me is that i grew up
in the town where the gummy bear was
invented after third grade i never miss
a day of school i've spent the last five
years living in miami working for the
parent company of burger king despite
this i have never actually tried a
whopper i actually got my pilot's
license before my driver's license i
absolutely love electric vehicles and i
want to work in that space but i just
can't drive fun fact i'm the proud
father of 13 house plants i'm a former
intelligence officer turned
investigative journalist one fun fact
about me is that as a modern dancer the
way that i prepare myself for
presentations is by doing handstands
somewhere where no one can see me i make
wine and continue 8 000 years of
winemaking tradition in georgia one fun
fact about me is that i'm extremely
passionate about travel i'm currently
visiting my 45th country in the
dominican republic fun fact about me is
that i actually make youtube videos i
was on jeopardy in 2012 and i got to
talk to alex trebek in a sean connery
voice and he loved it i am convinced
that i made the best quarantined banana
bread of anybody i know what i'm most
excited about is getting to meet you all
over the course of the next couple of
weeks
um in terms of advice that i would share
my neighbors
i'm most excited to meet all of you and
learn about all the different
backgrounds and passions we have in our
class
to learn
from you all to grow as hopefully
more than just a professional
or a leader but to grow as a person it
feels like it's been so long and the
time is finally here so i can't wait to
meet you all soon
what i'm most excited about is of course
meeting all the fantastic people that
are going to be sharing this journey
together and one piece of advice that i
would like to give to my fellow
classmates is to just be your most true
authentic self if i were looking back at
this at graduation i hope that by now
we've discovered our passions made
lifelong friends and come out stronger
and happier the best years of our lives
are ahead of us
please savor every moment of it let's
stay optimistic
take risks and
build the dreams that brought us here
mba class of 2023 congratulations
everyone let's make the most out of it
let's have all of those heated intense
discussions on all of those ideas that
may actually change lives change
organizations and change the world
[Music]